et présents à ce forum économique ferme
en grès bada premier ministre de la
république centrafricaine il est en
direct avec nous bonjour et merci d'être
en direct sur arte france alors dit plus
et quelles sont vos attentes vos
objectifs en tant que premier ministre
de la république centrafricaine lors de
ce forum économique de saint-pétersbourg
je
or manifestement on a un petit problème
de liaison
est-ce que vous m'entendez est-ce que
vous m'entendez je vous écoute manaa
vous n'entendez pas refait donc je
répète jacqueline springsource à parfait
monsieur le ministre je vous reposer
donc pas question quelles sont vos
attentes vos objectifs lors de ce forum
économique
[Musique]
je voudrais tout d'abord remercier
gouvernement de la fédération de russie
qui a bien voulu nous inviter donc
à participer à ce forum en second lieu
je
le remercie aussi pour l'accueil qui
nous a été réservé
la délégation qui m'accompagne et moi
même nous avons été très bien accueillis
ici à saint-pétersbourg pour répondre à
votre question je vais très rapidement
vous dire que revenant à ce forum
économique nous avions l'objectif de
trouver la possibilité de parler des
opportunités
d'affaires et d'investissement
en république centrafricaine bon vous le
savez la république centrafricaine est
un pays qui a beaucoup de potentialités
je m'en vais vous citer quelques
exemples nous avons de l'or nous avons
du diamant nous avons aussi dû boire
ce qui n'est pas insignifiant et
d'allemand nous avons une pluviométrie
qui nous permet de faire par exemple de
l'agriculture
toute l'année donc autant d'opportunités
que je suis venu présenter au nom du
président de la république son
excellence professeur phocéen contre
l'as des as et on celui du gouvernement
monsieur le premier ministre en quoi est
ce important pour votre pays d'échanger
avec des interlocuteurs économiques
russes ou encore français
pardon je disais en quoi est ce
important pour votre pays la république
centrafricaine d'échanger avec des
interlocuteurs économiques russes ou
encore français
bon quand vous le savez nous entretenons
avec la fédération de russie des
relations
diplomatique économique depuis les
années 1960
de même que
nous entretenons de très bonnes
relations avec la république française
qui reste d'ailleurs donc notre
partenaire privilégié en ce sens que
contrairement à ce qui se dit la france
donc soutien énorme à la république
centrafricaine elle continue de
l'appuyer dans tous ses programmes de
développement économique et social et
donc pour nous c'est important de
participer donc à ce forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg pour que dans une
certaine diversité nous puissions
échanger avec tous les opérateurs
économiques avec les hommes d'affaires
du monde qui sont venus pour participer
donc à ce forum de manière à ce que nous
puissions donc leur présenter les
différentes opportunités qui s'offraient
à eux a notamment dans le monde des
affaires
donc les opportunités d'affaires
également des investissements directs en
république centrafricaine pour ce qui
nous concerne comme je lai évoqué hier
sous l'autorité du président de la
république et selon les directives qu'il
a données depuis nous travaillons sur
l'amélioration du climat des affaires
plus concrètement nous sommes en train
de faire en sorte que notre appareil
judiciaire donc puisse garantir une
véritable sécurité juridique des
affaires
nous travaillons également sur la
révision de la charte des
investissements de
également nous avons un instrument de
relèvements en matière économique qui se
trouve être le rcp sia qui donne donc
les grandes orientations en ce qui
concerne les réformes économiques et
dans ce cadre général ce que nous
souhaitons c'est
le développement la promotion du secteur
privé pour qu'elle puisse donc donné
qu'ils puissent donner donc les grandes
opportunités d'emploi surtout pour nos
jeunes qui arrivent en nombre sans cesse
croissant sur le marché du travail de
façon à à lutter contre la pauvreté a
créé de la richesse donc
pour le développement du pays et quels
sont les secteurs privilégiés dans
lesquels la république centrafricaine et
la russie peuvent augmenter leurs
échanges économiques
[Musique]
bon ça y sont les secteurs comme je vous
le dis ici tout à l'heure les
opportunités d'affaires dans son immense
sont très larges
nous avons c'est connu nous avons donc
d'immenses potentialités dans le domaine
des ressources naturelles je pense alors
je pense aux côtés à mort je pense aux
bois nous avons le bois également de
très bonne qualité
je pense à l'uranium c'est de plus un
secret c'est connu nous avons aussi le
pétrole qui jusque là n'est pas n'est
pas exploité donc nous sommes venus
parler de tout cela et nous avons aussi
le
un domaine un moment important que celui
de l'agriculture il pleut toute l'année
entre +2 centrafricaine donc le secteur
agricole est d'ailleurs été un secteur
très important qu'il mériterait d'être
promu donc ça c'est les quelques
secteurs sur lesquels nous sommes venus
présenter avec qui sur sur lesquels donc
sommes en train de les changer avec les
partenaires de façon à les encourager
allez investir donc sur ces questions
les récents incidents à la frontière
avec le tchad a entraîné ont entraîné
des tensions entre vos deux pays y at-il
eu des avancées dans la résolution en de
cette situation
bon s'agissant de la dernière situation
malheureuse à notre frontière avec la
république soeur du tchad ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est que la république du
tchad
est un pays frère avec qui nous
partageons
une longue histoire une
l'ong géographie également une grande
culture
il est connu que dans notre politique
extérieure sous l'autorité de monsieur
le président de la république
le principe est celui de vivre en paix
avec tous les pays voisins lorsque vous
regardez l'histoire politique de la
république centrafricaine nous n'avons
jamais fait la guerre avec un pays frère
et voisin
ce qui s'est passé je dis que c'est
déplorable mais comprenez aussi que il
ya de cela plusieurs années la reprise
américaine vit en crise
elle connaît
une occupation d'une bonne partie de son
territoire par des groupes armés
qui s'y sont maintenus et qui entravent
donc que son développement après que
nous ayons bénéficié de l'appui de
certains partenaires du pays
qui nous ont permis d'organiser les
élections de faire face à la tentative
de la cpc de renverser les institutions
légitimes de l'état le 13 janvier
dernier nous avons plus la résolution vu
que certains groupes armés qui étaient
pourtant c'est à terre de l'accord
politique pour la paix la réconciliation
ont fait le choix de reprendre les armes
et d'intégrer la cpc nous avons réalisé
qu'il était dans donc non seulement de
les repousser
mais de remettre sous le contrôle de
l'état les zones qui étaient
anciennement occupé par eux et voilà
donc il est possible que dans de telles
opérations
qui est des incidents à caractère
militaire
mais face à la situation que vous
évoquez le présent la république de a
très rapidement pris l'initiative donc
dépêché auprès des autorités de la
république soeur du tchad
plusieurs membres du gouvernement
beaucoup
cette question soit évoquée en toute
fraternité sincérité et les résultats
qui en sont issues sont encourageants en
ce sens que nos deux gouvernements ont
retenu l'option d'ouvrir des enquêtes
impartiales indépendantes pour que toute
la lumière soit faite donc sur ces
incidents
malheureux monsieur le premier ministre
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir été en direct avec nous au puy
le forum économique de saint pétersbourg
sur arte france premier ministre de la
république centrafricaine frimin une
guerre bada merci à vous